good morning in -- good
afternoon I'm sorry and and
welcome everybody -- to the
city Montero are regarding
our hearing on first great
preparedness I'm for I am
assembly member Freddie
Rodriguez chair of the
select committee on local
public safety and emergency
preparedness and thank you all
for being here today for this
very important hearing also
want to thank those during
restore live video feed this
afternoon thanks for joining
us as well today's hearing is
on the subject of evacuation
plans at the local level
and earthquake preparedness
which stems from the recent
earthquakes that rattle southern
California July fourth and
July fifth earthquakes that
struck ridgecrest this year
were measured at six point four
and seven point one magnitude
earthquakes and ours are stern
reminders that server of quakes
can happen at any time and any
place and the big one is still
yet to come we'll be hearing
from representatives at the
state county and local level
whose testimony or provide
insight on how our government is
prepared to evacuate large
masses of people in response to
announce our disaster in this
case the server earthquake how
respond our community in a time
of disaster is only as good
as how well we have trained
and prepare for a career in
merchant services has taught
me that this turn will also
provide an opportunity for
members of the community to
listen and learn what to do
in the earthquake disaster and
who they must reach out to for
systems and information will
also put the legislature in
a better position to assist
local governments in preparing
and responding to earthquakes
and in all developing coherent
evacuation plans that will help
all Californians and ultimately
save lives I intend to take over
here today to work to ensure
that it even better tomorrow
by working with stakeholders
a residents also want to
thank those in advance for
participating here today at this
time I would like to welcome
-- my seat mate in Sacramento
assembly member Medina and likes
if he has a few words reform for
thank you assembly member
Rodriguez -- good to be
here -- recently got back from
Mexico City -- I chair the
select committee on California
Mexico and while I was
in Mexico City it was the
anniversary of two of their
-- past earthquakes both
of a very serious I I was
there for their -- drill
happen to be there on the
day that they were the whole
city of Mexico drilling --
doing -- evacuation drill
on that anniversary of both
of those earthquakes so I
know how important it is to
California I thank -- assembly
member Rodriguez for -- put
in this hearing together
and look forward to much
valuable information today
thank you without said there
will be an opportunity for
public comment at the end of
the hearing thank you all for
coming this afternoon and I
look forward to an informative
discussion and before we go for
those who I want to make sure
everybody who ever has cell
phones make sure we silence are
some phones we don't have in
your options as you move forward
so with that I'd like to invite
our first panel -- to come up
Jeff Tony who was the southern
region administrator for the
of the California office of
emergency services Mr turning
we look forward to hearing
from your review of the state
trump artists and preparing
and responding to an earthquake
disaster and how the state
assist our local governments are
responding to a disaster as well
as the status of the California
earthquake warning system
and the southern California
catastrophic or three plan so
with that when you're ready
good afternoon Mister chair
and members -- again I'm
Jeff Tony I am the southern
regional administrator for the
governor's office of emergency
services here in our southern
California region -- home
based at Los Alameda us on
the joint forces training base
that's our headquarters here
down south thank you again
for having all of us today
he timely has we know we all
got a little wake up call on
July fourth and July fifth with
-- the ridge crest earthquake
our office was a very active
in that response and continues
to be in the recovery as well
I'd like to start off pretty
basic -- kind of emergency
management one oh one -- with
the the number one tenant
and emergency management all
disasters are local they start
and the end at the local level
the state's here to supplement
to support how we can but
if the local government can
take care of it fantastic
and as you can see with this
slide here there's the five
different levels of response
as we do it in the state and
it's the standardized emergency
management system or Sam's
and this is the cornerstone
of our response and recovery
operations in the state
again we're in the city of
Ontario today if there were
an earthquake and the field
first responders can handle
it that's great if they need
additional support that's one
local government would step in
the city of Ontario they were
perhaps open their emergency
operations center provide more
specific portent resources
to our first responders out
in the field if it's bigger
than that may need additional
support they would go to the
county the operational area
-- the county has oversight
of all local jurisdictions
all special districts within
those county lines and if it's
bigger than that that's where
my office would step in and
Los Alameda stats are southern
California region were a big
region eleven counties and
if we need more support we
go on up to Sacramento at the
state operations center and
if it's truly catastrophic
then we as the state would ask
federal government and FEMA
-- for support and they've
been very close partners of
us in the past several years
and and additionally all
jurisdictions must use the
structure it's been not that a
construct that came about after
the nineteen ninety one Oakland
hills fire this kind adds more
structure to the chaos that use
the an incident command system
to manage incidents and it works
really well Californian and in
fact it was a it's a national
model and we're proud of it
so the state of California
emergency plan this is our
blueprint of how we do business
-- it's a great read -- I
encourage you to do it as well
as the public there's a lot of
fantastic information in there
again it's got a few parts to
it -- it defines our roles
and responsibilities who does
what in an emergency what state
agency is responsible for what
function it also spells out
responsibilities for local
governments -- and as well
addresses specific hazards
and here in California as you
can -- we basically have
any any hazard imaginable I mean
we we run the gamut we've got
volcanic hazards earthquakes
pandemic agricultural disasters
tsunami terrorism at cetera
etcetera this plan is designed
to address all hazards
also in this plan you can
find information on our mutual
aid system in California
we do it very very well in
in California -- the master
mutual aid agreement was
signed in nineteen fifty our
law enforcement agencies in
our fire agencies -- do mutual
aid I think better than anyone
and we're we're really lucky
to have that system in place
we also do alert and
warning communications and
cover all phases of emergency
management from preparedness
mitigation response and recovery
it also outlines how do local
government requests those
resources again I'll I'll take
you back to that Sam slide
go up that chain and when
when the government the state
whoever federal government
we want to fill gaps we want
to fill those needs use the
structure it's worked very well
now this is a big endeavor of
ours that we're doing right
now this is a rewrite of the
southern California catastrophic
earthquake plan we wrote this
plan in two thousand eleven
and I've spent the last two
years -- refining this document
-- we've had over twelve
workshops here in southern
California and a litany of
other working groups in meetings
all throughout the state
the plan covers and plans for
twenty one major earthquake
faults in southern California
-- but what we've decided to
do is basically plan for the
worst case scenario we plan
for that big the big one the
seven point eight earthquake
on the southern San Andreas
fault starting at the Salton sea
rupturing all the way up through
LA county and northwards even
answer Kern affecting twelve
counties this is a region wide
event and the numbers themselves
are pretty overwhelming -- we
front statistical models and a
scenario like this we could see
we could see twelve thousand
deaths over a hundred and
seventy five thousand injuries
buildings destroyed urban
fires going on infrastructure
down utilities down and an
estimate of two hundred and
thirty two billion dollars
in damage we wanted to plan
for the worst so we can see
what contingencies we have in
place locally the state level
and the federal level to deal
with consequences like this
and we're grateful for FEMA
they've been great partners
-- in this planning process
bear with me on the side I know
there's a lot of words but let
me let me take you through it
-- I want to first talk
about some of our partners in
contributors to the plan --
again FEMA -- department
of defense department of
transportation and other
federal agencies were all major
players in this -- the state
all state agencies played a role
in this -- local governments
all twelve affected counties
were key contributors to this
plan -- tribal governments
nonprofits and also the private
sector this is a whole community
approach we need everybody's
input we all have a vested
interest in this and this plan
FX nineteen million people
and we're all in this one
together so at the end
of the day we're gonna have a
really good products -- were
about eighty percent done
with the project -- we want
to socialize this plan as well
as test an exercise the plan
as well -- that's gonna happen
this upcoming year there
were two side projects that
coincided with this process --
we asked all twelve counties
to provide us with their fuel
burn rates what are your public
safety agencies use monthly
for fuel and we got a lot
of this information fuel they
say could be the Achilles heel
of this response there will
be a fuel shortage knowing
that information today is
really really beneficial should
something happen another side
project is come out of this is
logistical staging areas right
now we've done several county
is already were continuing
to do more we want to hit all
twelve here identifying key
points of distribution where we
can ship food water commodity
sheltering supplies so we now
can fifty three five three foot
trucks get in and out of this
area can we land helicopters
here can we land fixed wing
aircraft here so this knowledge
beforehand it will be absolutely
essential come come day get day
a game day and
-- the product will be good but
I want to just also emphasize
how important the process was
just going through this we
learn something every time we
did one of these workshops and
the more data we collected the
stronger we we will all be --
second bullet I want to focus
on I know it's tough to read
but this will make or break
your response the last
let's say three to four years
in California with our wire
well wild fires debris flow
mud slides said truly been
catastrophic so what has
helped us manage this is the
multi agency coordination
concept and the task force
concept so I'll give you a
couple examples for the wild
fires there's there's key
problem areas after any type
of disaster I column themes
you can call on tax task
forces mac groups what have you
so some of these commonalities
especially with the fires were
debris removal debris removal
is a huge deal typically the
most expensive component of
any disasters debris removal
housing task force where
people gonna live watershed
task force our watersheds have
been decimated by these fires
so we bring in geologists
hydrologists engineers
firefighters everybody to
analyze the thread a watershed
schools schools get disrupted
how worst our students going to
continue to learn and for the
first time animal task force
we stood up in -- the campfire
in paradise we had to feed
care for and shelter animals
for months there was a big big
endeavor small animals pets
large animals two horses mama's
you name it -- but this model
has worked and so you see in
in the catastrophic event you
see there's a lot more of these
groups and a lot more areas of
focus that we will need to hit
-- route clearance
transportation access will be
one of the first things that
will happen you need to get
to the side of the dam and she
needs a clear that debris off of
major freeways you need to make
sure our rail lines are back
up and running -- I mentioned
fuels and commodities we we
will immediately the state and
FEMA push commodities out to
these sites food water shelter
supplies whether it's needed or
not we want to make sure it's
there mass care and shelter
again housing and schools
utilities electricity so what
we need to do is gather the
right people from the right
agencies include the private
sector and form subject matter
expert groups to make critical
decisions and the tackle these
problems so this is it's worked
well in the past few years
this is just a hundred times
bigger than what we face so far
I did want to touch upon this
this is the unified coordination
group we call the UCG these
are the decision makers
all right this typically takes
place at the state operations
center the governor overseas
this but you have a high level
decision makers from from key
departments agencies and groups
you'll have the California
National Guard be a big player
the adjutant general probably
general bald one would be in
there my boss director dealer
dude she would most likely be
the state coordinating officer
you have a federal court navy
coordinating officer you'd have
the commissioner of the highway
patrol and there you have
Caltrans key agencies public
health department of finance
department of education --
FEMA's definitely in there as
well as a department of defense
coordinator it should we need
those military assets so you
have this core group and what
I do down here in the field I
send my staff out on the ground
to the field to county emergency
operation centers and the city
or city emergency operations
city to get out to to centers
to gather that informational
awareness female will do the
same National Guard will do the
same so you have all levels of
government shoulder to shoulder
in these emergency operations
center so it's right there
physically feeding information
and situational awareness up to
this you see G. group so they
can make the right decisions
when you're looking at a
scenario like this resources
will be scarce we have to
prioritize we have to be real
about it and this group will
ultimately make those decisions
not very excited about this
you've probably heard about
it earthquake early warning
-- this is a very very cool
newer technology -- that we
spent -- additional monies on
we did get funding in this last
budget round that was that was
great for testing and I didn't
know this until a few years
ago but there's actually to
shock waves that happens with
with that with the serious
earthquake it's called a P.
wave that comes first then
there's no shaking involved
with that a little burst of
energy there's a gap followed
by that damaging shockwaves
causing the the shaking at the
end and the damage and that gap
is key that gap could provide
needed seconds to act upon
-- we've got a sensor network
all up and down the state the
state those sensors pick up
that P. wave transmit it to
computer systems that run the
model how big was it where
was it how much time you have
very exciting -- we've had
a partnership with the U. S.
G. S. and also you -- UC
Berkeley with with a new app
that we're testing right now
and I am one of the experimental
app users at and I think it's
very exciting technology --
about three weeks ago we had
a four point oh earthquake in
riverside county in the town
of will the Mar I was sitting
at my desk at Los Alameda us
I got the earthquake alert on my
Pham H. it showed me three point
nine something it showed me will
the Mar and I sat there and sure
enough about four seconds later
got the little jewel it worked
in action I was very excited
to see it work in action and
four seconds is enough time I
I thought it was a three point
nine I did need to get under my
desk but had it been bigger I
would of those key seconds count
-- if it's five point our bigger
we have plans to roll this out
an alert people over cell phones
wireless emergency alerts so if
it meets a certain threshold --
entire geographic regions could
get alerts -- on your cell
phone and you know looking
into the future I would love
every California to have this
on their phone the capability
it has practical applications
if you're having brain surgery
I would really like the this
the surgeon to back away -- if
he gets that earthquake warning
-- in Northridge earthquake
certain fire stations couldn't
get their doors open because
they lost power so the fire
trucks could not respond there's
a couple stations in Los Angeles
county that are set up in and
hooked up to the system they
will automatically open so
that's a very big public benefit
-- the transportation sector
slowing trains down subways
that's very very valuable --
and could save lives pipelines
electrical grid shutting
things down pre shockwave
save a lot of money and a lot
of lives and there's much much
more -- so we're testing
it right now we're very close
and -- more to come on this
one and -- gentleman that's
all I have is formal testimony
but I'd be happy to entertain
any questions you have
can be in any questions are
just a couple questions I have
-- for more thank you all for
for the work you're doing out
there regarding the -- the
preparedness and portion of
everything and -- question is
how does Korea cow -- yes review
and share their emergency plans
with with counties and is that
something that's -- dated --
yearly or every other year I was
a so our our state plan
is available to to anybody in
California -- we assess counties
with the element of their
plans -- we review these county
plans we recommend updating
these about every three years
I think that's prudent things
change development happens
you communities change I think
three years is a good guideline
-- what we do is we have a
crosswalk where we will we will
run through the plan in its
entirety and will check off
if it meets certain elements
does it have -- alert morning
elements in it does it address
all the hazards so we review
it market up provide feedback
if needed and and that's our
review process -- working with
local government and then I
had another question regarding
-- was I think was the first
-- slide you showed regarding
health care in part of the
-- emerge response plan I
think -- -- this one here was
enormous on before or after
of light yeah healthcare
transportation healthcare sorted
mean by health care on that
of the public health component
pretty much for for -- when
you have so many injuries
-- so many deaths potentially
you have to you have to exercise
these medical health plans
it's a another medical health
side is a is a key component
partner of of any disaster so
that include sheltering support
that includes it could be --
patient evacuation that's
that's also things working
with them ambulance companies
working with department of
defense on how to of that
triage and evacuate patients
that's part of the process to
-- so they're they're a big
component partner but it's one
I'm asking I know -- when I
started the legislature a couple
years ago I know at the time
we have mobile field hospitals
-- because obviously we're not
big one comes at you know the
infrastructure alone is going
to be devastating out a we get
patients from -- from the point
of a disastrous was pretty the
impact to a hospital -- is
there any may be plans in the
near future regarding the use
of mobile field hospital since
we had about one time I know
the previous administration I
think what Swarts maker that
we had those mobile phone
hospitals now the kind out
when a way out of the different
that thinking now was there's
no never need for that is that
something you think that may
be revisited in the future that
would be a component -- and
and we have talked about that
one we do have medical caches
of supplies -- strategically
located -- we would lean
upon the National Guard and
probably department of defense
they have those capabilities
that they could set up
for us and just one last
question regarding the early
warning system -- so say the
earthquake is center here in
Ontario how far out with that
US alert would go to read
just a county or or to go by
jurisdiction or how how would
that work I I depends on the
size -- it you know and and
I can't speak to the specific
Al Gore them that they use --
I'll give you an example from
the the Loma Prieta earthquake
-- they had in nineteen eighty
nine I'm dating myself --
from the epicenter she if
this technology was available
then -- the marina district
downtown San Francisco would had
about twenty seconds occur of
warning -- but you know if it's
that five point oh magnitude
we want to we want to get it
out pretty far and wide okay
all right thanks a Jeff if
there's one of the questions
thank you overhead move with
the our second pounds thank you
now begin with the city of
Montclair and somebody in
accounting -- yes I'd like
to welcome our second panel
which consists of denim when
when you office assistant
emergency service manager for
the somebody in a county office
of emergency services and to
represent us from city Montero
Anthony Cannella fired ministry
-- director and Raymond Cheung
emergency manager as our next
serves our presenters come
to the table like to gain an
overall understanding of how
the city and county prepare for
earthquake disaster and respond
with a mass evacuation when
it's warranted respectively
so let's start with Mr manuals
go for when you're ready
good afternoon -- Daniel
millions of system emergency
services manager for --
salmon a Dino county office
of emergency services -- chair
culture -- happy to be here
thank you for the opportunity
to provide input hopefully
what I sure would be helpful
for you and for those others
that will utilize information
to hopefully strengthen our
emergency response instead of
California -- just just kind
of wanna piggy back off some
of the comments said -- Jeff
made more or more to provide
a a positive testimony to how
the process here in California
has worked and worked well in
my experience -- we utilize
a lot of the processes that
Jeff talked about just a few
minutes ago with our activation
a response to the -- recent
trona incident and still salmon
a Dino county we also have our
own -- emergency operations plan
IT UP which is available online
and it's a high level --
guide strategic guide for --
that outlines our operational
area the counties approach to
managing incidents and it's
no secret that we rely upon
the same to the Jeff mentioned
so basically my job the way I
explained it to folks is that
emergency management our primary
role is to bring organization
process and protocol in time of
chaos and we utilize out by
-- using those tools that Jeff
talked about the standardized
emergency management system --
incident command system the --
national incident management
system those are all tools that
we use while I don't expect
the the average member of the
public to be familiar with those
areas I think the confidence
that we can share with them and
and and the committee here is
that those that are involved
in our discipline are familiar
with those and we utilize those
tactic than those processes
to work well with each other
-- I work well with Jeff Toni
and everyone a callow yes so
Jeff also talked about and I'm
going to kind of jump around
here a little bit will this
presentation -- just to kind of
reinforced some points -- so
our E. emergency operations plan
obviously like Jeff mentioned
is also in collaboration with
-- community stakeholders
everyone from -- government
-- non profits --
business -- you name it
there are involved in the
providing input -- for
developing our emergency
operations plan but the the
thing that I wanted to kind of
focus on here and utilize my
time because I know Jeff did a
good job of touch in a lot of
these things here is that so
for example when when we were
-- impacted by the the incident
in trona and we activated our
emergency operations center as
Jeff mentioned all incidents
are handled at the lowest
local level still trona
is an unincorporated area of
the county hence that give us
those jurisdictional authority
to provide immediate support
to that area so part of my role
at the emergency operations
center was to -- coordinate
and dispatch a response to
help those impacted by the
earthquake so as part of that
response we immediately set up
what we call commodity points
of distribution and that's what
we could provide just basic
humanitarian needs to those
impacted things such as water
ice -- come for kids --
also -- -- behavioral
health services there and that
was set up -- probably within
sixteen hours of the of the
-- second or the primary --
earthquake striking those of
folks up in trona so that's
our rule at the EEOC no the
the other thing I wanted to to
stress upon is cal -- yes
is always available to assist
us so as soon as we activate
our emergency operations
center the state hello yes
dole -- activate their regional
emergency operations center
in support of our efforts so
there's this cascading affect
the folks being on stand by from
the local level to the state
level to the federal level if
needed and and the remarkable
thing about this process or why
it works is because it allows us
to coordinate in such a way that
we don't step on each other's
toes and so as a resources come
in whether they come in from
the highest level at the federal
level they're still gonna be
locally managed and coordinated
at the lowest local level so
I just wanted to highlight that
that system does work -- and
so I just want to bring that
to your attention the the other
thing is to in our world there
there could be a little bit of
a of a misconception perhaps
when we talk about evacuation
stern disasters well obviously
evacuations play a major
component to a lot of different
types of incidents where there'd
be a fire of flood man
made event or even an earthquake
but in this particular case of
trono -- there was a lot of
homes in infrastructure that
was damaged we don't necessarily
see a need for -- large scale
type of -- evacuation effort
the way we handle that and what
I have here up on the screen
right now is Sam regional
counties approach to providing
services to residents that are
dislocated due to an emergency
we have what we call a shock or
a shelter operations compound
into what we did up in trona is
we actually activated a hybrid
of the system and the reason
why we did that was because
the city of Rick a rich Chris
was gracious enough to offer
their shelter to provide shelter
services to the residents of
trona because of the logistics
involved it was the the best
approach to provide services to
residents still while we handled
a lot of the -- commodity
points of distributions in the
general trona area for folks
it needed -- shelter services
we transported those individuals
to the city of ridgecrest about
twenty twenty five miles away
if if something like this were
to happen in a different part
of San Medina county and we
did have to offer -- activate a
shock then the shock would
provide the county a basic
one stop shop approach to
providing services for those
impacted which would include
-- sheltering medical support
-- anything from that there's
an election going on we can
set up -- our register office
of voters can set up -- --
place for folks to cast a vote
of we have pretty much every
single county department at our
disposal including -- behavioral
health department of aging
chill Jim services preschool
services but in addition to
that the great thing about it
is in collaboration with with
the state is we can bring in
state resources department
of motor vehicles department
of insurance or any other
department where there's a
needed gap to provide services
to the residents so so that's
kind of our approach for the
county and a shock is is really
and -- designed to accommodate
anywhere between three thousand
to five thousand folks that
have been displaced due to an
emergency so so we're really
proud of that program but I
think most importantly for us --
is that we've tested these plans
and so there are their battle
tested we realize that one no
plan no approach is perfect we
feel highly confident in our
ability to execute -- these
plans in this process is to
be able to provide services
to those that are impacted so
that's that's sort of in a nut
shell the county's role and
so you know if we you pose the
question of what if the city
of Ontario would would face to
an earthquake well our our
response would be to rely on of
my friends and my partners here
Mister Collette on Mister Chung
they would be the first ones
that would coordinate resources
here at the very localized level
activating perhaps probably more
than likely they're emergency
operations center that in turn
would trigger us to activate
our emergency operations
center and that will create
the cascading event for kello
yes to activate their regional
emergency operations center so
I I I say all this not knowing
everyone's -- understanding of
the processes so I take this
opportunity is an advocate
to just kind of share that
information -- I know that
there's members of the public
and others who that might not
be aware but that's the process
that we use your and local
government so with that be
happy to answer any questions
that's a which square had move
onto city Montero so whoever
like your first the afternoon
and and thank you for having us
today -- my intended
to Tony's afternoon instead
of kind of how we do like
business in local government
-- my name is Anthony Clint
a mystery director venture --
fire department our department
responsible for providing fire
rescue related public safety
service in the city's hundred
and seventy eight thousand
permit residents one thousand a
hundred thousand daily visitors
and commuters and fifteen
thousand daily passengers
to the International Airport
the charges within my command
is oversee a fire departments
emergency management division
also known as a cities office
emergency management with this
today's entered as emergency
manager Mister Raymond Cheung
is responsible for the direct
oversight of the city's
emergency disaster readiness
in this is having the capability
and capacity to stand up to
extraordinary emergencies and
disasters government has plans
procedures equipment tools
supplies and train staff to
help us meet this responsibility
readiness may be summed up as
having the plans procedures
resources to a stand respond
to recover from extraordinary
emergencies and disasters these
plans procedures and resources
are then employed or deployed
by well trained equipped and
capable staff a compendium
of achieving readiness requires
a purposeful and meaningful
cycle of planning equipping
training exercising evaluating
and adjusting to changing the
threat environment lessons
learned from past disasters
and changes in local emergency
response in support capabilities
local governments emergency
planning capability building
city building is centered
on the specific threats and
hazards to that jurisdiction
these threats and hazards then
analyzed and assess to quantify
associated risk involved
abilities to the community
plans procedures capabilities
and capacities are then built
around those that are needed
to withstand respond to recover
from threats and hazards that
pose the highest risk and
have the highest probability
of impacting our communities
threaten rest each community
are dependent upon many factors
not limited to climate geography
elevation population population
density built up infrastructure
and other factors each of
us here today representing
different jurisdictions levels
of government have our own set
of threats and hazards unique
to our communities with this in
mind or individual preparedness
efforts as mentioned today --
well based on the same sound
emergency management principles
practices and standards will
be unique uniquely premised
upon our own particular needs
emergency evacuation one of
those emergency functions unique
to each of our own communities
the city of Ontario enjoys a
relatively flat terrain well
protected by exceptional flood
control devices a measures
and devoid of any significant
wildland urban interface
wildfire threat as such our
need to conduct large scale
evacuations in the face of a
major flooding debris flows or
wildfire is a low risk and low
probability event are back you
Asians are limited to small
scale evacuations prompted by
localized more routine events
I such as structural fires
has is materials releases the
law enforcement operations
earthquakes would be an example
of a high impact event with
wide scale in broad implications
to all jurisdictions seated
here today evacuations result
of a major earthquake would
likely be in response to
uncontrolled fire has a natural
releases untenable business
or residential structures
these again would more likely
be limited to small sailboat
decorations Senate on localize
risk conducting mass scale
evacuation moving large numbers
of people from one affected
jurisdiction to another affected
neighboring jurisdiction in
response to earthquake in
most cases would likely not be
warranted and made it virtually
an impact the receiving
jurisdictions I who have also
likely not seen the effects
of the damaging earthquake
the carry out emergency
functions such evacuation the
local government level we rely
on several established emergency
management plans and systems
many of these already mentioned
today but these do include
the California standardizing
burn to management system the
national emergency incident
management system modeled
after California system the
incident command system multi
agency coordination system at
a local jurisdictions emergency
operations plan while these
plans the system the rigidly
structured they allow for
flexibility and now such service
frameworks that can be applied
to any disaster or emergency
these frameworks then allow
for emergency functions such
as evacuations to be executed
even in the absence of unique
and specific functional plants
as my colleagues may agree to
California is local government
you're a subdivisions are
uniquely postured to withstand
extraordinary emergencies
and disasters we are well
equipped trained and exercise
to the size scope repetitive
nature of the state's disaster
portfolio I like to close with
this our readiness requires
purposeful and meaningful keep
building capacity building
disaster response recovery
requires executable plans
teachers and systems employed
they well trained and well
equipped personnel our internal
capabilities any discernible gap
in capacities are complemented
by California's robust
emergency management system of
cooperation resource sharing
mutual aid for the supported
by flexible and expandable
emergency plans and systems
thank you with that
will move on to a Rendon
city Montero thank you
thank you and good afternoon
-- Raymond Cheung city venture
emerging manager -- so
our partners of already talked
about a lot of the systems and
processes and procedures we
have in place to manage a large
scale disasters I'm a take this
opportunity to talk a little
bit about our specific programs
at the local level because as
Mister Tony mentioned -- all
disasters are locally managed
a summer -- kind of highlight
a few of our -- programs we
have in the city of Ontario --
here in Ontario we do have -- a
what we call a hot or full
time emergency operations
center I will talk a lot lot
about UC's saccharine already
as we are very very fortunate
to have this -- UC available
that -- it would take only
minutes to activate verses --
maybe several hours of for
a cold EOC and call the OC is
one and may not have tables
or chairs a laptop Sir other
equipment out unfortunately --
you know many cities do not have
the resources to have a hot UC
-- and we we are fortunate to
have that -- so what are you
see we've got you know it it
Davey system with projectors
laptops out phones satellite
phones communication equipment
-- and so we were very very well
prepared -- in this facility to
be able to manage a a disaster
-- that the UC is that place
where -- mortal agencies can
get together when that face
the face shoulders shoulder
environment where -- we really
we we can come together and
solve the biggest problems
at hand and face to face can
occasions always the the best
kind of communication I in terms
of how we organize in the UC
if you know it's a standards
management system -- dot dot
it's a command systems Sims
nam's -- and these concepts
really are -- based out of
-- the military as well as
standard business management
concepts of their tried and
true -- men and we use them --
every day in Amherst management
-- at the local level typically
any UC's led by you see director
-- and that person is usually
the city manager or a police
chief or fire chief -- that's
pretty standard throughout
-- the cities in California
-- there is the -- wall for
elected officials you know
they may be what's in the it
was called the policy group
advising that you see director
on certain -- high level policy
-- changes or direction -- that
-- you know maybe concerning
to the community as a whole
one of the programs are very
very proud of here in the west
end of San Diego county is what
we call the regional you see
academy are we all know that
training is very very important
in terms of you know how we
prepare for that -- that big
disaster -- you know there's a
saying that them the more you
of sweat in training the less
he pleaded combat and we truly
take this to heart a and one
the ways we train is through
this regional you see economy in
the west and this does consist
of the cities are on Terrio
Rancho Cucamonga -- Chino Chino
hills and one player -- and
with this is a collaborative
effort where we get together and
jointly train -- the personal
in our cities to our work in
the UC's we take a standard
set of classes offered by the
state of California and these
classes are used to fulfill our
the a a state type three you
see position credential that
will allow those those
-- personnel to you know be
basically trained basically
qualified to work in any UC
-- I'm during a disaster --
like I said is a collaborative
effort you know all all of
our cities are limited in our
resources so we always want to
work together in both response
and the prepares phases --
of -- of immersing act and
they get the job done hi this
is a bi annual Academy so I
you know it it's something
that we we have -- ongoing
-- throughout the year
I of course you know
having the public repaired is
also very very important you
know that's why we're here as
public servants we are here to
serve the public -- so we spent
a lot of time on ensuring that
the public understands how
to get prepared and the methods
-- used to get prepared -- out
like that that are gonna altered
a single bit but -- you know an
ounce of preparedness is really
worth the pound a response
-- -- so we we really try
to get the public prepared --
as much as possible -- this
we we do conduct up for merit
preparedness booths at at
a public events a year long
-- year round -- we do a
preparedness expo -- once years
well -- so we take as many
options as you can do to you
know have those touch points for
the public so they cannot they
understand that really we need
their help and and -- preparing
the community as a whole
a part of that era is just
something that just pass is
actually a September is national
preparedness month a and now
all of us immerse managers go
through a lot of different --
efforts to get the our public
prepared during this month
-- just as an example -- in
Ontario we conducted a few
of these events including --
Skender hides -- and -- quick
escape room a and a kind of
a role playing disaster table
top exercise I would try to
make these events as fun and
engaging as possible because
you know disasters are not
necessarily the the -- no
most fine topic that do think
about or discuss so we try to
-- act use that route that
engage -- engage folks the
the get the better prepared
another way we get people
prepared is through our radio on
Terrio campaign -- this includes
a website that we host as well
this website is kind of our
our one stop shop preparedness
portal for folks in come in and
they don't have a communications
plan or business continuity
plan they can go on this website
and download a template to fill
out also includes a different
supply lists that people can
go out and you know if if they
need a Mrs by the don't know
what to get you know we give
them that list on and also
a volunteer opportunities for
people to if they want even
more involved or learn how they
can participate in the response
efforts on those are listed
here as well additionally even
real time instant information
we include a map on there --
that if we had road closures
our shelter locations evacuation
areas things like that that
would be shared on on this
website another way we share
information because information
we now -- during disaster is
probably -- on the our most
valuable resource there is
-- mass notification system
or alert on Jerry was a we
call it here -- in the city
-- we are very lucky to have
a -- mastication istom system
and on this system includes a
land line numbers -- that we
purchased through the phone
company as well as people who
register their cell phones
-- and email addresses -- --
for us to contact them during
the -- during an emergency
-- so information again like
shelters and evacuations
I would we would use this
system to notify the public
out we also managed a cert
program are too many Mercer
Spahn steam on this is response
focused we all know that
during a big disaster are
for sponsoring me extremely
excellent extremely busy --
and are going to the highest
priority events and -- the
public you know they may not see
those first responders for quite
sometime if they're not that
one those you know begins in
locations so we trained --
these folks to be able to -- at
home and in their neighborhoods
be better prepared as well as
what are the kind of response
tactics necessary to survive
those first few hours first
few days of that disaster all
this in training clue it's a
disaster medical operations --
disaster preparedness disaster
psychology US team organization
and fire safety because we know
that of fire following work
week is probably going to be
no one of the the -- big causes
of damage I during that scenario
all this is also a way to get
-- our members a public engaged
in the disaster response process
that as well as during the the
preparedness phase so I it it's
a very very well loved program
and and we're happy offered
here in the city of Ontario
another program that -- we just
kicked off actually is what we
call the leaders and prepares
academy of this concept is is
new and growing -- throughout
our region and and possibly the
state of this is very very close
to what the intention of service
but really concentrating on the
prepare his days were Sir is
really looking at response this
is all about preparedness -- and
-- giving the folks the the
knowledge -- of what
systems we do have in place
a lot of things we're talking
about here today but really
how they can impact you know
preparedness -- individually
so -- you know at the end
of the series of classes is
currently nine classes about
twenty hours long of a multi
agency -- multi disciplined --
had a training where we have
so cal gas so cal Edison our
water department -- police
fire -- is a nor sage called
by operation hope which is
about financial a disaster
financial literacy no it's a
collaborative effort -- and
at the end of this class of
each of the individual graduates
makes what's called prepare his
promise where they think about
and they actually you know --
make this promise to do more
to do something you in you their
their -- place of business their
school -- their neighborhood
you know somewhere where they
can really be be that ports
of change and act as a leader
within -- the -- a disaster
preparedness so I we're we're
very hopeful that you know
this will continue on and
grow and and hopefully really
-- impact meaningful change
-- in in the state --
couple things out of weird
-- concerned about in a
at the local level -- is
-- sing link that we we --
want to improve upon our
alert warning so what I talked
a little bit about our --
-- mastication system --
up earlier -- so we're very
lucky to have a master of
creation program of this the
state of California recently
released the learn warning
guidelines recommending that
all cities have us system like
this unfortunate all cities
have that the resources as
we do this bill will have the
system -- and some so something
to kind of keep in mind
as you -- go about thinking
about how we can improve the
systems in the state it is
whether it makes sense for you
know maybe the state level to
to have a a statewide system
and that really helps in terms
of you know marketing the
system and ensuring more people
registered as a lot of times
we do not have a cell phones or
email addresses of for people
so we rely on an opt in system
-- -- I know that in Orange
County have system call alert
-- see and it being a county
wide system allows them that
additional marketing effort --
to get those folks registered
within the county so it's
it's a big benefit -- and with
the state having fifty eight
counties forty four animations
municipalities you know that
kind of effort I really would
go a long way to a shared
how the last thing I want to
touch on is you know in terms
of all will populations we
understand that the most
vulnerable among us or the
most likely to be victims and
disasters we know this from
every single disaster -- that
we research -- you know today
you know there's a state as said
that forty percent of Americans
cannot paid an unexpected formed
all the bill I know then that's
is not for us you know daily
day emergencies but a massively
affects how people are able
to respond to recover from
disasters wall odds with
yelp nationwide this is an
issue and especially in terms
of from look at our homelessness
crisis are how however you know
it it again it it will impact
our disaster recovery efforts
-- as well so you know efforts
to try to contain that crisis
is going to do a lot more than
just the day to day it's gonna
extension into the -- disaster
world -- and that's all Ortez
might have been a happy to take
any questions thank you okay
thank you with that I think --
some rumor Medina had a question
or two to ask I did thank you
very much a lot of valuable
information I especially
appreciated your addressing
what individual families can do
to prepare something that was
-- brought up by our colleague
-- moon Monique Limon own
who represents Santa Barbara
and in their -- wild fires
and mud -- catastrophes
that she dealt with and that
she brought up legislation and
the day -- would like to hear
is addressing the the public
who who speak very is different
languages and the difficulty
that Santa Barbara had in that
in their communication and I
believe that she introduced
in and got legislation passed
on just that so I prepared
it art would would your cities
be in being able to -- address
-- populations that speaker
don't understand -- English
hi I can take that so --
we again we are fortunate
on cherry to have a massive
cation program -- and through
that program we do have the
ability to do -- to to have
templates to have AB multiple
languages -- of pre translated
so and so we're able to reach
the but those populations
-- more effectively -- again
you know we are lucky I
don't aye aye I don't think
too many jurisdictions have
that ability as well as
we do to be able to that
thank you
I had a question regarding --
the search teams that we have
here Montero office I think
those are a big help for our
first responders because --
pretty much be the first ones
are and some of these -- areas
so how many surgeons does
on Tero happened with that
-- is -- the county somebody
notices cities like on terror
-- regarding -- certain
qualifications or I should
say -- getting more folks
involved so we currently have
you know one one on two Sir
team -- you know we're what
we're looking at is building
additional neighborhood teams
-- you know that's kind of a
something we we wanna -- to
more of in the future as as
we build out -- the program
for sure broke from the
county side we actually manage
multiple Sir -- programs --
in our unincorporated areas
as well as some of the city's
for example we help the --
city of Fontana upland grand
terrace we also have many
unincorporated areas that --
we oversee there Sir programs
we receive -- -- funding
specifically to support those
programs in addition to that
-- -- real exciting in terms of
also system with communication
as we also have a least those
program which the emphasis is
for our Spanish speaking folks
-- and so that that program sort
of mirrors a cert program but
it's for individuals that don't
speak English it's for folks
to speak Spanish and we're also
taking a look at -- expanding
that -- to other folks were --
other other languages including
-- Vietnamese -- so it's
it's something that we we are
sensitive to and -- we're
real proud of our Sir programs
also -- regarding -- the city
Montero plans is that something
on terror you update yearly
every other year and it's one
thing we do have the plans
but is there any table top
discussions are or how the
plan would working case that a
disaster comes because we can
have all the plans we want both
we don't practice those plans
update those plans they're no
good so just curse of of what
you guys are doing regarding
the plans sure I'll go ahead
and dress that -- so our our
mercy plans Jeff pointed out it
is is there on I I don't under
update cycle -- but typically
is we we periodically --
completely revise rebuild that
plan every three to five years
-- however is every exercise
every training event every post
disaster -- critique and
evaluation is we go back it back
and just those plans because is
we've are adjusted capability
we are bill capacities we've
applied those lessons learned
and that's kind of when the
important things that we do
is we identify lessons learned
from previous disasters but more
importantly is we apply those
lessons learned to enhancing
or bolstering those plans and
capabilities so to to kind of
that the direct cancer is after
each exercise each disastrous
EOC activation out we update
revised those plans okay
and -- one of his one elaborate
expel a bit more what are some
remember Medina talked about
the language barriers with some
of these communities -- power
plants not only with those
folks but with the individuals
-- the children the elderly and
disabled communities right how
do we assist them in vacuum with
them as well do we have plans in
place for that as well I would
imagine so -- yes Sir actually
were required to have -- not
only language there are plans
but we also from a practical
standpoint that that's one of
the key things that we actually
exercise only trying to so so
really what we're talking about
is the axis and functional
needs community which could be
anywhere up that has perhaps
will we would recognize more
traditionally as a perhaps
a a disability in terms of
maybe somebody that's bound
to a wheelchair but it also
includes people that may not
necessarily speaker understand
English those could be folks
that could be identified as
per potentially having an
axis and functional needs --
-- ability to comprehend
so we're sensitive to that
to those components are built
into our plans but as as my
colleagues have said from a
practical standpoint is exercise
in that so so we absolutely do
and also wanted to say that from
the county's perspective we're
real proud of the fact that it's
not just about the plants the
plants just one component it I
I use a sports analogy if we're
not gonna practice and we must
not will help plants because the
plans are not going to be able
to be executed unless people put
in sweat equity so I'm really
proud to say right now is as
we speak right now votes for my
department actually conducting
the table top exercise with our
elected officials so something
that we take very seriously
we're very prideful and it's
something that it this committee
can take back -- anything that
we can get in terms of support
for ongoing not only funding
for exercise programs and
training critical to what we do
okay thank you very much for
that assn in any of questions
okay thank you more with that
will go ahead and move on
to our third and final panel
with that will have -- Chris
Malard risk manager from
city of Pomona sergeant Caro
X. from for the Los Angeles
county sheriff's department
and send and con associate
director of response with the
LA county office of emerging
management so with that -- will
go head start with the city
of Pomona when you're ready
shop
good afternoon and thank you
for -- inviting us to take
part in this discussion --
this afternoon -- unlike
-- many jurisdictions of the
-- responsibility for the city
of homeowners -- emergency
preparedness program falls
under the risk management
division of the human resources
department with the city --
the day to day handling of the
emergency preparedness program
is handled by Alex remembers
who is our safety and emergency
preparedness analyst -- I
oversee Mister repairs and also
assist in the development of
our program and we both report
the end to the human resources
and risk management director
Linda Matthews at city Pomona
-- unlike most agencies
the city does have an
emergency operations plan
it's an all hazards plan
doesn't concentrate just on
earthquakes it -- covers
-- of multiple disasters
should they occur -- the
operations plan is posted on
the city's website so it's
available to -- anybody that
would log on to the website and
can take a look at it -- it was
adopted by the promoter city
council in July two thousand
eleven -- we are in the process
now of updating that plan
-- and it's expected at that
process will take a look a
little bit to get through
-- we also have a hazard
mitigation plan -- to go
along with that as well --
in the event of a disaster
emergency large healers quick
the city would -- activated
its emergency operations center
-- the -- operations center
is manned by city personnel
assigned city personnel --
if it happens during business
hours -- employees assigned
to the center would would --
be instructed to respond there
in and soon their duties and
and pass that their sign if it
occurs -- in the -- --
off business hours the employees
have a call in number that they
can call and they'll be given
instructions if you're assigned
to the emergency operations
center then you report there it
whether it's a nation after a
bi shift -- and if you're not
assigned there then you're the
employees are advise with the
to come to work or not and maybe
other duties -- will be assigned
the -- emergency operations
center is housed at --
Brackett field in la Verne
-- we have just completed
the movement to that --
in its -- it does not
I wouldn't call it a a hot
emergency operations center
as -- the city of Ontario
ours is more of a a warm --
we do have -- --
equipment -- station that and
in the the helicopter hangar
-- and it could be activated
within thirty minutes of of
the should the need arise
-- as the -- event unfolds our
EOC will provide support to
the field and first responder
personnel -- and we will also be
in contact with the Los Angeles
county emergency operations
-- the city will communicate
with LA county through the
or system -- the operational
error response and recovery
system -- that's -- and
an online -- reporting system
in the event that that is not
available -- there are --
hand held radios that we can
also reports -- to the county
-- it through this system
should the city of Pomona
need additional assistance
we can make the request
through LA county -- and
hopefully -- resources are
available and if not then --
the county will escalate the
request up up the line --
is as far as LA county -- they
have divided the the county
into -- a disaster management
areas -- a through H. the
city of Pomona is a member of
area D. which is composed
of approximately twenty three
cities in the San Gabriel Valley
-- each area has a -- disaster
management area coordinator
and it's just -- coordinator
who will be the liaison between
the city of Pomona and LA
county should the need arise
as the -- event
unfolds -- and -- we
-- you'll see personnel are are
trying to get a handle on on the
extent -- of the disaster
and and keep in mind --
the first responders will
will be out there to the EEOC
its job is to support -- the
first responders but as we
we are able to get somewhat
of an idea of what's going
on the city will then deploy
a damage assessment teams --
and we will use those to try
and determine that the scope
and extent of the damage that's
been caused critical areas
that need more assistance
than others -- and the needs
for additional resources --
if the -- disaster occurs
during business hours in Pomona
has developed -- an employee
evacuation plan -- we're we will
evacuate -- the employees from
city facilities -- so we can
get them out safely -- and
once they're evacuated the
proceed to assign areas where
-- for lack of better term roll
call can be taken -- so that
we can account for personnel
-- and its personnel are
missing -- then we can advise
the first responders when
they arrive on scene that that
either everybody is accounted
for or there are missing
personality was in various
departments are for whatever
we've also a as part of our
program -- we have designated
for a community centers as
emergency evacuation centers
-- we've designated --
Washington Park Palomar's park
west month park inclination
park -- and -- residents
-- will be instructed to to
-- proceed to those centers
-- if they can't get their --
we have had discussions with
foothill transit hopefully we
can use public transportation
to help get them there -- also
potentially using an used city
vehicles of if we have to roam
the streets and and pick up
people and and get them to the
-- evacuation centers the city
of Pomona has entered into
agreements with the American
red cross for shelter operations
-- and assuming they're
not overstretched they will come
in and and run the -- shelters
after they've been set up by
city staff city staff have
been trained -- in setting up
-- the shelters and doing the
initial running until American
red cross -- comes on site
-- the as far as notifications
-- the notification system that
the city currently uses called
Mixels it's through the police
department -- it's a voluntary
sign up -- residents can sign
up and then they'll receive --
messages -- for for various
things and in the event of
an emergency messages will be
sent out -- we've also
-- would rely on faith based
organizations the they are are
-- well -- in tune with their
communities and they can
help get the word out as well
-- if if worse comes to
worse we will also use these
damage assessment teams and
and city employees to go door
to door to knock on doors
-- vice people of of --
need to evacuate -- and
-- things of that nature --
we have a --
it is four hours -- other
notifications we we can also use
the -- police helicopters well
it's got loudspeakers and --
also police vehicles -- that can
roam through the neighborhood --
Mona itself does not have a
search team -- although there is
a Pomona valley -- Sir team
-- it is a -- a team is made
up of -- individual citizens
-- it was originally -- put
together by cal poly Pomona
-- when the -- operations
-- emergency operations
individual retired there she
continued on -- and maintaining
that Sir program we have
-- run some city employees
through Sir training -- and
-- that is a program that we
will pick up again -- in the
future -- and that's
all I have at this time
okay thank you with that --
sergeant are crumbling before
so we're actually getting
going to myself and so
on Connor -- we're gonna
do this together and the
reason why we're gonna do it
together is in LA county --
when it comes to emergency
operations emergency management
by county code the sheriff is
director of emergency response
in our county emergency
operations center and we're
partnered with the office of
emergency management which
falls under the CEO's office and
-- office emergency management
-- CEOs office comes directory
of the director of recovery
so recovery begins at that
starts at the beginning of any
disaster so word cohabitating in
the same building and we support
each other and collaborate
daily on -- issues within
the county of Los Angeles --
just an overview of --
LA county it's over four
thousand square miles -- the
residential population is
around ten million but giving
any Monday through Friday
depending on the time of day
that population could --
rise to fifteen million of just
with all the business in all
everything going on in LA county
LA county has eighty eight
independent cities -- their
forty seven independent
law enforcement agencies
twenty two independent fire
agencies in over one hundred
special districts so we have
a lot going on in LA county
-- our emergency operation
planned for LA county we we
call it the -- E. R. P. R.
acronym for the operational area
emergency response plan in in
that plan that that delegates
roles in a door -- authorities
-- who's in charge of our --
county -- see what the city --
sees are responsible for what
the sheriff departments OEM
office emergency management
it just outlines roles and
responsibilities in that plan it
also talks about our county
EOC actually has two functions
it is the county emergency
operations center for the eighty
eight independent cities however
it is the emergency operations
center for unincorporated
areas within the county
-- and then it also Daly
talks about the roles and
responsibilities of the special
districts within the county
in an example of the special
districts would be our --
water districts are school
districts that they all have
a vital role when we had that
really bad day in LA county
-- that is a brief overview of
our Marin T. operations plan
or operational area emergency
response plan but within that
plan there are many annexes
that are added to that plan and
I think the topic for the days
evacuation during emerging --
a major earthquake in in that
plan there is an evacuation
annex M. then corporates
the whole operational area
I would say this that with
any plan it is only good
until the day that bad day
happens -- one of our first
priorities in our county
emergency operations center
in out earthquake scenario is
to gain situational awareness
throughout the county because
we do have a valuation plans
but we have to validate and
that that those emergency routes
are still viable with the
catastrophic earthquake we know
that over passes are gonna be
compromised and I do a lot
of earthquake preparedness
training for my department for
my partners within the county
and I challenge every class
every time I teach a class
especially on earthquakes like
challenge the class to count
the number of over passes they
either have to go over or under
leaving my class I I
my office is in east all the
city of east LA I live in the
city of Long Beach it is twenty
six miles for me to commute
to work it took me three days
to get the number right because
I heard something nice on the
radio and I lost count but
for me to traverse twenty six
miles I either have to go over
or under fifty six overpasses
and we know that in a
catastrophic earthquake over
passes are going to fail
they are designed cal tech
are -- cal tech and --
-- how can I get
a Caltrans Caltrans they tell
us those overpasses a section
of those overpasses are designed
to fail if the earthquake
is big enough and the reason
for that is it's cheaper
and quicker to repair that
overpasses if we lose the whole
over pass so I challenge my
students count those overpasses
in that just starts the
preparedness level for everybody
within the county so now I'm
gonna turn over to sit on
so as my colleague
from Pomona pointed out
each city is responsible for
their own emergency management
cop aspects however it's very
unlikely that once if in in any
significant amount specially and
earthquake dot one is impacted
and dot shockwave absolutely
stops at the boundary of that
city that is never going to
happen we live in a communal
society where we all have to
work together so even though
cities hop independence there
is a very strong sense of
collaboration between all cities
and the county across the mac
areas Bob to work together
okay this starts with
preparedness initiatives where
we all reach out to each other
we all show up when one cities
actually hosting a community
preparedness event to share
materials even development of
these materials is done in a
very collaborative fashion thank
if you're preparing together we
need to train together the last
thing I want to know is the last
thing I would really want and
an American the county emergency
operations center is meeting my
counterpart for the very first
time off for a major earthquake
through our operational area
training and exercise during
committee we have created a
collaborative that gives us
all an opportunity to work
together towards developing
trainings hosting trainings
or exercising whether these
are table top exercises which
are discussion based to actual
boots on the ground scenario
or even an EOC activation
in terms of the operational area
Bob as Jeff up Tony mentioned
earlier we look at building
blocks okay we follow sums all
the way through so if a cities
impacted the need assistance
there are always going to reach
out and we're always going to
be there to help Bob in terms
of an event where we do have
a notice in advance there have
been instances where -- city
asset I'm sorry county assets
have been pre stage to be able
to assist local jurisdictions
one of the biggest things
is how do we get information
out to the public especially
when it's around evacuations
Los Angeles county uses
the alert LA county system tax
and of course I cannot find the
brochure right now what
the alert LA county system
actually does is any land
line is automatically registered
into the system so if an
emergency happens and we have
to push a messaging out all land
lines will get that call okay
individuals can also register
their cell numbers their email
addresses and if they have
pagers pager information whether
they would like to receive text
messages and dot message can
be pushed out by our sheriff's
department the message can be
in multiple languages and it
also has accessibility features
and with the alert LA messages
it it is a very robust
system and we can we can
push an alert message county
wide for we can be a surgical
with who gets that message we
can we can even draw down to
I can notify the Norse out it
north side of the street and
not the south side I can not
pinpoint one house and not their
neighbor -- we use it for all
emergencies and disasters --
it's extremely user friendly
and -- from initiating that
or making the decision that we
need to push out or not -- alert
message it takes about five
minutes to designate the area
that that messages going to type
the message and hit send the
system will let us know how
many residents a contacted how
many contacts failed and then
it'll also re dial each number
three times and let us know in
in actually give us a report
one of the drawbacks of the
system depending on if we trying
do a county wide message
because it the algorithms in
the computers doing it it's
not gonna happen immediately
it's gonna take hours for
that system to contact
ten million people however
we've used it in very local
emergencies of up to two hundred
thousand people in the and in
down messaging was completed
within two hours -- so it is
a very robust system and we're
really fortunate to have it
so moving on to --
evacuation shelters
receptions up centers
LA county house several most of
them are out our park and rec
facilities they have all been
assessed for accessibility okay
making sure that our facilities
are inclusive is a huge priority
it's usually the red cross that
takes the lead in setting up
the box centers our reception
centers -- up immediately
offer emergency but there are
several county resources that
have been there whether it's
in an unincorporated area or
a city jurisdiction dot how
provided services that includes
our department of public social
services department of health
services mental health senior
services programs as well as
our homeless services programs
up moving on to public education
there are a lot of programs
that we have heavily push
forward with the biggest one is
our emergency survival guides
these are available in multiple
languages up fourteen languages
and counting up the moment
our push really is to get
the community ready K. the
last thing we want is for
any resident think off okay
I have received evacuation
notice for any emergency up
for after an earthquake my home
is damage I need to relocate
to a shelter what should I be
taking me okay the purpose of
these guides are to make sure
that our residents are prepared
in advance the other companion
docking up booklet that we have
is Stacey stand control this
is specifically geared towards
people with disabilities and
others with rocks and functional
needs to be able to conduct a
self assessment on what their
needs are going to be during
any emergency our focus really
is all hazards because some
of the things that you would
need for one disaster would
definitely carry on to the other
and then as far is situational
analysis and damage assessment
like our colleague said from
commodity at in in LA county
we use the operational area
resource and recovery system
the acronym is orders it
is a web based system --
wars does two things for us
a four eighty eight cities
that incorporated areas in
our special districts it
is a tool that is used for
-- those entities to provide
situational awareness to the
to the county level what
what their status is -- what
resources they need and and
how they're faring that is
one of the tools we use to
gain situational awareness
and to give us give me to
develop a common operating
picture within the county --
so what with the wars in our
our partners in Amman and they
have a really bad day in Pomona
they can log in to orders
develop a situation report
-- we would see that in the
county and then we could follow
that up with phone calls and
they get it it would give them
the ability also if they need
resources they can request those
resources through wars and then
we would follow that up with
a phone call to make sure we
understand the exact resource
requested what exactly they need
and then we would dispatch us
resources your startup growth
and as far so as far as drills
and exercises -- I I I think
everybody that's been up here
on the panel has basically
said we play like we practice
so exercising and drills
whether it's for conducting
a workshop going to a table
top to a functional tool for
skill functional -- we were
constantly doing that within
the county with our our city
partners are county departments
-- in our special districts --
we have an annual evacuation
drill into paying a canyon
it's one of our big concerns --
in and that's a it's a fire
scenario for that particular
drill but in that community
there's only two one way at
the north in one way out of
the south and -- thousands
of residents live there -- and
that is an annual drill we do --
regarding earthquakes in LA
county we participate in the
great shakeout every year and
-- some years that that drill
is more elaborate than others
but every year the basics
of that exercise is we request
that all the city's all our
county departments and all our
special interest rate districts
log in to orders and give
us a situation status report
and N. during exercise it could
be make believe what we are
we are up and functioning or
we are devastated but it it's
that muscle memory of getting
them to use the system to for
that that situation status
report to the county level in
and we do that annually and
we have to drill together train
together exercise together up
dot is that as a mantra for
the entire operational area
that's it if you have any
other questions or the three
is great to hear I'm I'm really
pleased to to the information
but a question for approach
for both city put more LA
county talked about homeowner
the the community centers and
LA county talk about some of
the resource committee senator
at some of the park something
so is there already supplies
there at those locations in
a bit of a of a disaster okay
we go there because that's
the evacuation center or site
clusters already stockpile of
supplies there for the for
the city of Pomona we have some
supplies -- we are in the
process of of trying to augment
what we have on hand -- for
the issue we have is is finding
places to store those -- but
-- is this a going forward
we are going to argument
-- but we do have on hand
in the and then from the county
level -- as far sheltering is
concerned -- American red cross
is one of our main partners
in that at the county level we
never know exactly where that
disaster is going to be so we
we don't have pre
stays supplies at potential
shelters because we never know
where the disaster is going
to be in addition to that we
don't know we we have lists
of potential shelters but
depending on the disaster
that shelter may be affected
the infrastructure may be
compromised so we do not
have pre stage supplies
at shelter potential shelter
locations but we do work closely
with red cross and once we
we need to activate a certain
sheltered then we immediately
dispatch -- supplies and
support to that shelter
when I was going out to that
one of the things that we
actually lead was up we work
with the American red cross --
for durable medical equipment
what their needs would actually
be we created a list with our
operational area partners we
actually procured those supplies
Bob and they're managed by the
red cross but as my colleague
from the sure sponsored the
red cross is the one that
actually moves those assets
around up there not actually pre
stage simply because we don't
know where the emergency will
I am done for city appoint you
talked about there isn't any
really active Sir or new Connor
is a certain but not really
so to speak it is so they're
looking at maybe wrapping that
up somehow to make sure we
have the teams there as like on
our sister city here in Ontario
as of the system operating
wrecked it there is there is
a certain team -- based out of
Pomona but it is not a city of
Pomona searching -- as I said
it's it's made up of independent
jewels from the community
that will really formed by
-- the emergency preparedness
person for cal poly Pomona --
as I said one of the things that
that we would like to do we have
train some city employees --
said the to the cert program --
in we would one of our
plans is to get every city
employee through that program
as well -- and hopefully
establish a city of Pomona
certain in spring of promote
a particular I know you made
much of the beginning regarding
a year the O. C. at Brackett
field that's somewhat odd being
outside is actually a technique
city laverne so something
happens in in Pomona and say
infrastructure we talked about
the bridges only talk about
bridges right comma so many
bridges obviously the main
arteries I'm thinking about
in the top of my head -- Whyte
Avenue Gerry Avenue there's a
couple the over under passes
right does go down so would it
be harder to get folks out to
la Verne in case infrastructures
down so kinda defeats the
purpose we have he'll see but
it's technically not in Pomona
it's outside the city and we
have to travel there in a case
we have that catastrophic event
were you know how we gonna get
there because X. one G. the
streets or blocked off then
what we do is our backup plan
the there there is -- the we
do have certain vehicles --
with the police department --
ex military vehicles we have a
a Humvee -- and then was known
as a and M. rap that pretty
much will climb over everything
if worse comes to worse we can
use the helicopter to -- pick
people up -- the -- ill
see used to be in the basement
of fire station one eighty
one -- on Park Avenue --
unfortunately when the -- Chino
hills earthquake occurred --
quite a few years ago now --
we did activate our our EOC and
everybody went down into the
basement and we determined at
the there's there wasn't --
very good air circulation there
was only one way in and one way
out through at the staircase
that that made a couple of turns
-- in it it -- was felt that
that was a somewhat inadequate
-- in so we we looked around
and the -- the best location
the we could come up with was
the -- you sharing space with a
helicopter at a practice field
it's a one story a cinder block
building -- should --
the power go out because of an
earthquake it's an airport they
will have power -- there is
it run ways of emergency price
mercy supplies need to be flown
in by helicopter whatever they
can be brought into Brackett
field and then disperse from
that that point -- we are right
across the street from the
Fairplex -- we are partnering
with the Fairplex -- is they
have -- -- as part of their
their program that they have a
lot of facilities -- showers it
and what not that people could
use -- and they could also be
used as a an evacuation center
okay and not just one last
question for somebody or LA
county folks being were so big
and fast in the population over
ten million how I mean are
we really working with our local
cities are eighty eight cities
writing we talk about the county
to make sure that everybody's on
the same page so to speak when
it comes to the big catastrophic
event cause I know sometimes
communication falls through the
cracks and people don't really
know everything one thing that
comes to mind we sure thing was
alert LA I don't even know that
was here now it's like wow I've
been put more in in telecom
whole life and I didn't even
know there was that -- after
you can sign up so how are we
making sure that we're getting
all the information out to a
regular constituents going to
be hard even some areas because
of disadvantaged communities
and maybe not access to internet
stuff how I mean do we work
with our cities to try to do
our best to make sure that the
information is out there with
everybody up absolutely that's
actually a great question there
are several mechanisms that
we do that through up first
which would be our operational
or a training exercise during
committee up the demon axed
out of my colleague from Pomona
referenced earlier are a part
of this committee as well as
cities that of that represent
themselves of this committee
this is where we plan out our
training and exercise calendar
over three years this is
where we plan our operational
area exercises up over a
two year period okay --
in addition to that there are
up for example on your question
your comment regarding alert LA
county as it turns out multiple
dot cities and Alec are fiercely
independent so cities you do
have their own up emergency
notification system case in
point Pomona actually uses Nixle
for load of local notifications
when we actually go out for
community education we carry
a list with us to make sure
that the resident is getting
the right information so if they
are resident of a city dot does
not how Fuller daily county to
have their own system we make
sure that we direct them to the
right side up at times we do
take laptops with us especially
when we're out senior centers
to make sure direct registration
is taking place and individuals
are registered for the court
Bob for the proper system now
the systems do have crosstalk
capability of our sheriff's
department is actually great
reaching out to partner agencies
to make sure that the correct
message is going out of to the
right areas in addition we have
of a group called one voice
intercom anytime there is an
incident or even if it even if
they're just training to prepare
for one this one weighs group
actually house representation
from county departments as
well as external partners up
throughout the operational area
and we make sure we are putting
out one of accepted
message nobody is pushing
out conflicting information
when you said that and we talked
about the fires here in northern
California in the napa area and
I think there was some of the
issues because some individual
cities have their own evacuation
alert systems and the counties
had difference in that were
the conflict because nobody was
really communicating they're
pretty messages out someone
someone were in some weren't
so there's just conflicting
so hopefully that we don't do
things like that oversee it
in this part of the state what
our system that we have that
maybe there's a unified plan
how we everybody's on the same
page right regardless of what
alert system you have that when
something happens that were
are alerting the folks that
we need to alert regardless of
what system you're on yes Sir
so with that said I want to
thank you for bringing your
information for to without the
concludes our portion of our
panels so now I would like to
invite members of the public if
there's any that would like to
come forward to for a a two
minutes at a time to share
any information if there's
anybody out there in the public
I think you can come forty here
to the to the from your to the
the the podium in the front
good question I'm gonna mark
Casey from Chino from what I'm
hearing from Chino when I'm
hearing from there it sounds
like they'll have some shelters
and some resources available
but they can't take in everyone
so I'm assuming for the
cities in the county guys would
you rather we have someplace in
place and we hunkered down at
home a listing of our house is
really in bad shape actually so
that we don't flood the
shelters you don't have water
and food for all this right
okay broach the yes
the grocery of some from
somebody in here that
would hopefully give
us some insight to that
okay yes ma'am so again Daniel
millions from the county of
San Bernadino emergency --
office of emergency services
so for your particular city you
actually have -- any emergency
manager and the reason I know
that is because she used to
work for our department she
was recently hired by your
city so you have a full time
emergency manager and so the
city of Chino has their own --
he -- shelter plans in place
so we would augment that
should they be needed by the
city of Chino so the way our
process works if there's a a
van that impacts your local
area -- the the city of
Chino would provide services
to the point where they can
-- they might not have the
resources needed then they would
reach out to us at the county
level then we would come in and
augment those services whatever
they may be but my question
is shouldn't high have something
in place so that I can stay
at my home whether it's inside
or outside June I have some
bad in some extra clothing some
food so that you don't
have to bring in extra mean
if I can stay there wouldn't
you rather me stay at my home
rather than run to shelter yes
ma'am absolutely a we encourage
all of our residents to -- take
preparedness efforts -- which
will include not only items for
yourself and your loved ones
but also what we encourage is
for folks to think about things
like their pets -- and things
of that nature anything that
residents can do to be self
sufficient will greatly --
-- enhance our efforts in in
the recovery response phase
of thing so the less folks we
have to worry about the better
the response is going to be
for the over arching approach I
think most people think you're
going to take care of them we
don't need to tell me
if I watched my neighborhood my
family my friends my neighbors
there's very few of us that
have kids in place they think
you're going to take care of but
I think they need to learn the
opposite you need to take care
of yourself first and if you
absolutely can't we're here for
you I I agree with that ma'am
it's kinda okay thank you and
I was just wanted to get back
with that ma'am I'm sorry to
get your name but I think now
more than ever we need to vice
are or -- cities and really
are a residents that if the big
winner cursed to be prepared
right there should be a list of
things you should have at home
the clothes extra clothing food
medication sub but people don't
talk about some medications a
lot of our structure orderly
folks arm some medical
conditions and need to have
those so I think we may have
some information on my website
but before you even talked
on my staff about some stuff
we can have some information
then I think you're I
think for the most part a
yes so that's the any other
folks for public comment the
thing seen on I want to thank
everybody for coming -- thank
our panelists for the and
public for participating today's
hearing each of you provide
constructive and thoughtful
insights that help us better
understand how our local
governments are prepared và I
create a large mass of people in
the event of a severe earthquake
if any my colleagues of would
like take many comments -- but
then he already left already
look for forty dollars in the
near future I also want to
invite you all to my upcoming
emergency preparedness expo on
Saturday October twelfth which
will be held at the marker
senior center from eleven to
one it also just want to let
folks know that a recording of
to the sharing and materials
will be present available on
my website in the next few
days that in with that said
this informational hearing
is adjourned and thank you
all for being here thanks